what do you think is more important
EQ or IQ EQ being emotional intelligence
in terms of uh in what makes us human
emotional intelligence is what makes us
human it's
how we connect with one another it's how
we build trust it's how
we make decisions right like your
emotions
Drive
kind of what you had for breakfast but
also where you decide to live and what
you want to do for the rest of your life
so
I think emotions are underrated
um but so emotional intelligence isn't
just about
the effective expression of your own
emotions it's about a sensitivity and
empathy to other people's emotions and
that sort of being able to effectively
engage in the dance of emotions with
other people yeah I like that
explanation I like that kind of
yeah thinking about it as a dance
because it is really about that it's
about sensing what state the other
person's in and using that information
to decide on how you're going to react
um
and I think it can be very powerful like
people who are the best most persuative
most persuasive leaders in the world tap
into
you know they have if you have higher EQ
you're more likely to be able to
motivate people to change their
behaviors
so um so it can be very powerful